well a reality star from The Real
Housewives of DC cat ominay who claims
she well actually did have a flick with
Prince Harry doesn't claim it I think it
was true so she's been whitewashed from
history and doesn't recognize the party
Prince she once knew cat joins me now
along with royal corresponder Vanity
Fair Katie Nichol and Fox News
contributor Heraldo Rivera welcome to
you to this uh Stellar panel I must say
um and thank you Gerardo for joining us
from across the pond I'll come to you in
a moment cat I want to talk to you
because this book was coming out spare
it's supposed to be Harry's story but I
suspect we're going to get a very
sanitized version of anything which is
awkward for him and it'll just be more
of what we've been seeing now for the
last year and a half which is just
constant attacks on his family and the
media
or total snooze Fest right I mean you
know the but the title I love the title
thing is a great title but you know how
much he's influenced about how he wrote
it and what's in it who knows you were
34 when you met a young 21 year old
Harry yeah so a bit of a Madonna
situation going on there
really well she likes the toy boys
didn't she well yeah yeah I was
criticized because I didn't really care
about age you had a little fling with
him uh it was well documented and got
pictures of you there what was he like
then as a young guy
just really really really funny total
gentleman totally down to earth normal
and did he carry any of this enormous
baggage which he now appears to have all
the time because he seems just
completely miserable
he did at the time
now he just seems completely miserable
all the time this Freedom he saw it
doesn't seem to make it yeah I mean what
I saw with him at the time he was
desperately searching for freedom and
and privacy and yet what he's done is
completely turned the whole situation
full circle right and now he's got no
privacy and no Freedom well they invade
their own privacy every 10 minutes
that's the sort of irony of this
position I mean Katie we've talked a lot
about this um and the reason we keep
talking about it is because on Thursday
there'll be another dump yeah of three
more episodes in this Netflix snooze
Fest which a lot of it is very boring
yeah wait for it well yeah it is boring
actually it's very self-indulgent very
narcissistic but in the middle of all
this there will be more barbs we know at
the royal family and the media you know
and they'll play the oppressed victims
well it's really interesting hearing
cats say that actually because I think
when you look at those pictures of Harry
party and I started my career as a royal
correspondent because I ended up at a
party with Prince Harry and you know
drinking bottle of vodka and having a
great time and he seemed like a very fun
guy but it's interesting hearing you say
that he seemed like someone that sort of
wanted to to hide away from from the
media who wanted to have his private
life and I think that is the massive
contradiction in in all of this but as I
unpick his his complaints and this
resentment and it's bitterness at the
heart of this is bitterness about the
institution bitterness about how he's
portrayed in the media and I think now
that he's actually named William in this
latest trailer and I think clearly
William and Kate and and the sussex's
relationship with William Kate is going
to come under scrutiny I think there's a
lot of sibling rivalry at the hospital
is I think Harry and the fact this book
is called spare has rescinded being the
spare for a long time and I think we're
going to hear much more on that
particularly I agree with you um Geraldo
across the pond
um it seems to me a lot of Americans are
as fed up with them as we are I think
you're still hanging in there as being
not necessarily a fulsome supporter but
a more tolerant uh Observer of all this
what do you make of it all
well first of all I want to say I
thought of you appears when Harry Kane
missed that shot I really I felt very
bad for you and for uh for England uh
thank you you know in terms of the the
Netflix uh documentary and Harriet and
Megan uh you know in their participation
and you know their their ongoing soap
opera I really do feel for them and I
think that the vitriol being heaped on
them the the scorn is so snobby and
snotty it's having absolutely the
opposite effect I believe that they are
generating some sympathy now not because
of what they're doing on the Netflix
show as much as a reaction to the
British tabloids and this incessant uh
constant uh you know criticism there is
no doubt in my mind that they are they
are telling the basic truth maybe
there's a you know a shot here that
should not have been used a stock
footage of a footage of photograph
photographers and so forth but I think
the general truth emerges they seem
sincere they seem beleaguered they seems
I've got to be honest with you you are
one of the people I most respect in
American television news you're a
hard-bitten journalist you're a war
correspondent and you've fallen for this
Guff with these two Hook Line and Sinker
because they're the least sincere people
I've ever met in my life
she's an actress she's playing a role
she's a good actress my brother I told
you peers I told you how I followed
Prince Harry into Helmut Province yeah
in Afghanistan and how the American
Marines there and the British Personnel
that were still there after he had left
all all considered his service there to
be honorable even here no question so I
come as a reward correspondent I come
with that bias here's a guy who served
his country honorably put his own life
on the line he married a woman who for
the first time in British royal history
was of mixed race so the issue of racism
and here Harry's girl Straight Outta
Compton and all that kind of baloney uh
they have been assailed uh you know I
feel for them because they have been
targeted in a way that I feel is very
very unfair yeah I would argue okay but
I would argue they haven't been targeted
in the way that I think a lot of
Americans have been led to believe they
were targeted there was no racism to
towards them in the mainstream media in
this country there wasn't the papers
here were euphoric about this The Daily
Mail the Daily Mail just did 20 pages on
the Netflix document 20 Pages
that's because it's obsessive yeah but
Heraldo that's because
these two sought freedom and privacy in
America and all they've done since they
got there is Cash in on their Royal
titles afforded to them by an
institution they despise and are trying
to ruin and they're making hundreds of
millions of dollars
you talk about Iraq around am I in
Afghanistan my my brother served in Iraq
and Afghanistan right and in fact my
brother-in-law taught William and Harry
at Santa's Military Academy so I I
absolutely respect his military service
but if my brother notwithstanding his
heroic War record in Iraq and
Afghanistan went on National Television
every 10 minutes dumping all over my
family that would be a very short
conversation next time I saw him you
just don't do that kind of thing to
families well you know there where is
the kindness where is the where is that
activity when here you have a here you
have a young couple trying to find their
way an extraordinary situations with
scrutiny that is that is so absolutely
intrusive they don't have a moment to
breathe now he is the spare he is the
the one that was designated to take over
when you know I understand all that and
I understand the frustration of that I
mean uh theoretically but I really do
believe that you are your lack of
kindness to them is laid bare peers you
can't have such a visceral uh
viciousness
he's just trying to pave their way in
the world where's the irony my response
to them is driven by their serial
unkindness and viciousness to the royal
family and their deliberate attempts now
to not only attack their family who is a
beloved family in this country but to
actually destabilize and potentially
bring down the British Monarchy and as a
monarchist who loves the Royal factors
they're not going to bring down the
British monarch well it might touch
they're not going to write down the
British Monarchy they they will not how
why what I'll tell you why because
they're constant centuries-old
institutions because they're constant
framing of the royal family is a bunch
of nasty callous racists is beginning to
hit home in America it's hitting home in
the Commonwealth people are believing
this they're not producing any actual
evidence to support the racism claims
all the other mental health when you
have it the headlight the headline
literally read Harry's new girl almost
Straight Outta Compton right come on
peers come for your viewers not familiar
with this area of Los Angeles is like
Harlem in New York there's a lot of nice
places
I thought that was an unfortunate
headline but the piece of the company
that was euphorically praiseworthy and
the truth is she comes from an area
about five six miles from Compton and
Compton produced as far as the British
audience is concerned produced Serena
and Venus Williams so they wouldn't see
it in a particularly negative way they
think oh that's the best even making
your even speak all right even speaking
of Serena and Venus you you put it in a
racial context here she here she is a
mixed race actress you know who's not
has no familiarity she wasn't debriefed
by Sarah Ferguson as far as I know or by
really anybody who who could guide her
into the intricacies what about her own
house the etiquette and so forth
she was hung out well he can't advise
knew what Harry can do but he's a guy
he's it's not like she didn't have
someone say here's how you curtsy she
didn't have someone to say eventually
they loved Queen
around us you're believing the [ __ ]
she literally got given a massive
dossier explaining all these things it's
now been revealed most of what they say
in this Netflix thing is completely
understand lady and waiting
it seems to me that you have an anger
inside you that I don't know what the
source of it is but I think that for
example to to allege without proof that
this couple is a is imperiling the
British Monarchy is a grotesque
overstatement I don't think it is
historic significance yeah I don't I for
because of what because of what because
any role
played any role in the way that they
were treated specifically the
allegations of racism against the royal
family for which they produce zero
evidence all they've done is smear the
entire family
well I think that I I think that this
was a great lesson for the for not just
the British people and the Commonwealth
but here in the United States a great
lesson in the need for sensitivity uh in
the need for to have a when you have a
progressive step like this that for the
country to embrace them I think that
Harry would like nothing better than to
go and to help the I heard you were
talking with the labor leaders earlier
about the unrest and the economic
difficulties yeah I'm positive Harry and
Megan would like to be part of a
Representatives
they've got no interest in helping in
the cost of living crisis over here
you've drunk the Sussex Kool-Aid
I I think that if you gave them a CH if
they if the reception had been a bit
more understanding if they if you had a
little bit more positive of a fair Shake
we couldn't have been more every time
how do you feel how do you you and I
have had our own uh Adventures over our
long public lives how would you feel if
every day you woke up every single
tabloid in the country was tearing you
apart or was scrutinous
that was uh actually the coverage was
incredibly positive I remember it well
yeah until it wasn't peers The Narrative
did change
let me just think about it I rather
you'd be brilliant as always as a guest
I love the way you speak your mind I
love the way you never compromise when
you have a belief about something I
appreciate you joining me so thank you
very much all right let's get a reaction
to this I just want to make a lot of
Americans by the way will agree with her
album they do they do but the narrative
did change but it didn't just change
because newspaper afraid it just sat
there saying right now let's put the
knife in no it changed because their
behavior changes
they became very hypocritical preaching
about the environment using private jets
preaching about poverty throwing half a
million dollar baby showers and by the
way they've made some pretty damaging
allegations in this of the trailers
anything to go by I mean the idea that
you know the palace were briefing
against them what I know from my
experience covering this beat for a long
time that their press aides were doing
everything they could to keep those
negative stories out and you know they
were so that's a there's there's
potentially quite damaging allegations
in all of this and you know Geraldo
mentioned proof well are we going to see
any proof are we going to see any
evidence to the next three we're not um
what are your thoughts now maybe you
bumped into Harry what would you say to
him
I just didn't know whether I'd actually
even recognize him anymore
I mean I've changed so much I mean
personality wise
because when I watched him like with the
show
I just thought wow it's almost like
and my mother will really hate me for
saying this
but it's almost like she's got like a
spell over him and
um that's why I don't recognize him
because he used to be saved like down to
earth and normal and and it's only so
little of him I've actually recognized
you know Joanna Lumley has come out with
an interview with the times in which she
says that she's horrified by the way she
talks about women specifically but I
think it can extend to men as well that
you can become too much of a victim you
start to celebrate victimhood you lose
the strength and she believes that this
generation is losing the strength of
previous generations she was talking
about women but I think it applies to
men as well that there's an almost a
celebration of playing a victim right
but I mean he it would never in a
million years have
um back in those days have ever been
that person to do this show no I mean
looking at the front pages we've got up
here this is the coverage of when they
got engaged it couldn't have been more
euphoric same for the wedding they had
18 months of great press coverage they
got a lot of attention because they're
the biggest stars in the country when
you marry into the royal family anyway
we'll leave it there there's lots of
different views we'll have all these
views on Piers Morganite sense so that's
the whole point of the show is that we
will invite people to have different
views to mine and to challenge mine
that's great
um doesn't mean I'm wrong
thank you both very much indeed for
coming in still ahead